frankly bizarre we're not going to show
the full video um but we are going to
show some still frames from it which i
should warn that some viewers might find
upsetting kurt zuma can be seen dropping
his cat and kicking it with quite some
force across his kitchen floor like a
goalkeeper would do after picking up the
ball
he's also seen the west ham stars also
seen chasing his cat around his house
hurling shoes at it even at one point
slapping it in the face again really
quite forcefully all the while laughter
could be heard in the background of this
video it was filmed on sunday uploaded
to snapchat and since then the former
chelsea player has issued a groveling
statement quite a lengthy one
he says
i want to apologize for my actions there
are no excuses for my behavior which i
sincerely regret i also want to say how
deeply sorry sorry i am to anyone who is
upset by the video i would like to
assure everyone that our two cats are
perfectly fine and healthy they are
loved and cherished by our entire family
and this behavior was an isolated
incident that will not happen again now
his club west ham have publicly
condemned his actions and the footage
though and have vowed to investigate
this
internally rspca have also spoken out
again against it so i think there could
well be some repercussions to come
okay do we know where the cat is
uh we don't but according to kurt zuma
it's alive and well still in his house
but as i say uh some potential
repercussions because the rspca have
said they may well investigate if they
uh receive any complaints
makes my blood boil this sort of stuff
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot iva
cat's this big he is a professional
footballer and he boots it across the
kitchen allegedly and his brother thinks
it's so funny not only does he take the
video but he then posts it on snapchat
because they think they've done nothing
wrong
allegedly